[Music]
in down with the dorms news submitted by
what does BBC stand for it's not the
British British news station I thought
it was big black [ __ ] yeah I think
that's what they were you know we need
to join their network the the British
new thing you should respond back and be
like I don't condone big black [ __ ]
that's messed up mit has upset the
campus after shutting down its famous
dorm which hell's the school's misfits
MIT has MS and mighty misfits are they
like you know what they're the hackers
of mi tele that's what they are maybe
these are the ones that study the drugs
or like the Nerds that picked on the
other nerds like yes doing [ __ ] it's
yeah so I'm a little bit jealous too by
the way
why those kids I go to MIT they're like
geniuses I just feel like their brain is
operating on a completely different
level and I wish I was that smart I
don't care
they're probably not [ __ ] that much
well they could be [ __ ] a lot yeah
they really are
I'm just hating probably like
trajectories and [ __ ] to see which one
feels better what position feels better
swings they're like perfectly
perpendicular that's because the college
I went to everybody was too busy trying
to make a living that they don't have
time for fun
yeah MIT is shutting down this dorm
called
senior house and it's not a house just
for seniors like all students can go
there so this is the oldest dorm it was
opened in 1918 Wow and it used to be the
only living quarters for students but
over the years the house transformed and
became well known for like the misfits
which are the writers rockers artists
game transgender people felt like that
was a safe haven for them in the school
since like the 80s also its misfits it's
kind of like what people identify
themselves at yeah I feel like I don't
fit in with this group yeah I got an
engineer but I like rock or something
yeah exactly
they're saying that this dorm is a place
where you can really just be yourself
and not worry about other people judging
you and so excuse me you can be yourself
anywhere without worrying about how
people judge you because they're gonna
constantly judge you what's it like in
the other dorms then like why do you do
specific dorms feel safe in the other
dorms everyone wears their pants above
their belly button so yours is below
that everyone clowns the [ __ ] out of you
so cut your feelings I think it's
because when you're staying with other
freaks that you're like you feel less
crazy do you get to laugh at someone or
is just comforting that be around people
that are similar to you you're an MIT
man you're already cool he's [ __ ]
awesome no but they're all the same it's
mainly people who like support the live
free or die kind of mentality what's the
difference right there's the rest of the
people students right there and they're
not live free or die I don't know oh
they're the responsible think about the
future and these guys are the [ __ ]
drugs now consequences later I kind of
want to go there and just visit them and
talk to them why was there too much
drugs so the board was saying that they
found evidence of like drug use there of
course every single dose yeah every
single college has drug use yeah what
the hell you're talking about
yes omic decided to shut this dorm down
because they were saying that they were
citing low graduation rates drug use and
dangerous behaviors also people are
dropping out of that specific dorm no
there is just that they out of all the
dorms on campus they just have the
lowest graduation rate I see yeah so
it's 99 percent instead of 100 78%
percent yeah that's almost 80% yeah what
do you mean graduation like people
actually finish because it might be that
these misfits are potentially finding
other things like mr. Facebook Excel in
you yeah they like oh I'm not gonna
graduate but now I just started up a new
business or do something else and they
left so
lack of graduation doesn't mean these
guys yeah but then they are saying like
the drug use from the dangerous behavior
because there was one student that is
facing charges for having a firearm in
his room so that works against the dorm
um he's trying to protect you you're
welcome okay if they said something like
okay guys we had twenty overdoses within
this first week we we can't have that
much drug use anymore so there are these
other objections saying that other dorms
have been sites of suicides and even
fatal drug overdoses but none of those
other dorms have been shut down so what
are they speculating there's more is
this like bit like is this the crack
house dorm of MIT but even that dorm is
like pretty much 80% graduation probably
yeah like they're just very [ __ ]
crackheads some of them don't make it
there but a lot of men copy within my
high school had eighty percent
graduation I didn't graduate they're
saying that the the reason why they're
shedding those dorm down though like the
real reason is because of the image that
this dorm has already is ugly which is
like the misfits dorm
so then after shutting the storm down
are they gonna like rebuild or rebrand
this dorm yeah they are rebranding the
dorm and they're saying that they're
gonna transform it into a different
style for incoming freshmen it says
quote from rock climbing to meditating
to rolling my shirt or baking bread you
can do it all in this new residential
program that is designed to support your
acquisitiveness by offering you a
spectrum of opportunities so it seems
like it's really like corporate wash now
like now the whole branding of this so
that's kind of fun though they get to
explore all kinds of stuff you don't act
like the hipster dorm yeah seems like
they're trying to make it more like
cleaner image and so people that are
currently staying there they're gonna be
scattered across all these other dorms
and they're just gonna find like a tree
and go under and do a bunch of drugs
like well they don't like it what the
people what people that are being
dispersed well no they don't from their
crack house do you choose what dorms
they go to know that like the schools
Norm's for you I don't know no know
anything about college life right I'm
like man if you got into MIT you could
do it or the [ __ ] you want you want to
bring a gun to class who cares he's
gonna turn that gun into a [ __ ] like
rocket ship or something you guys mess
much yeah that shit's like MIT is like
the science Harvard you know so for me
it's like you got into that school
you're [ __ ] the brightest of the
brightest of our country you could do it
over the hell you want you want to stick
jelly beans up your ass go ahead he's
[ __ ] measuring the trajectory for that
too who knew uh [ __ ] bidets mm-hmm
yeah so they're saying that there's been
a lot of successful people come from
that dorm like the creator of the Tor
software which is the Onion Router
professors doctors lawyers employees for
Google Amazon red and Apple Mike they've
all come out of that dorm so it's like
yeah I wonder what are like the majors
that are good at MIT you know how like
ecology Davis is like farming and then
like Riverside is like orange a
technology it's just technology anything
science or text based so math physics
engineering all that stuff it sounds
boring to me it's just kidding I think
it's pretty dope because one of my
favorite books
it's called bringing down the house and
it's about the MIT students that went to
do card counting and Las Vegas Lee yeah
and you know what [ __ ] that movie
because all the students are supposed to
be Asian and Middle Eastern oh really
yeah they're always yeah because
specifically in the book they were
saying that they didn't really recruit
white students because it was pretty
common that really mil middle and the
whole rich Middle Eastern and rich Asian
kids would come to Vegas and blow Mad
Money so they wouldn't raise suspicion
yeah white people stand out too much
yeah because they're not known to be
pressing gamblers like a lot of like
rich Persian or you know Middle Eastern
kids and Asian kids that's why so then
they recruited that group they came in
and then they would have this whole team
would like just [ __ ] card count and
make all this money and I was like dad I
was the first book I read from page to
page yes a former student and resident
of senior house objected saying it's a
place of expression and Trust it's a
place where you would where you were
always free to be you it pushed the
culture of MIT forward and kept the
weirdos there it was a week before they
announced that this dorm was closing
during a commencement speech the Apple
CEO Tim Cook he gave a speech talking
about this he said quote empower the
crazy one The Misfits the rebels and the
troublemakers the round pegs and the
square holes do the best to do the best
working with you and so now they're
closing that door that's why do people
always encourage these like outwardly
kinds because I mean they never give
love to normal people like us like
there's always like some kind of ooh
let's give attention to all the weirdos
and all that [ __ ] and I'm all like why
they didn't work for it but there might
be something I mean they mean like
weirdos I think outside the box they
work yeah you literally work not speak
for yourself
weirdo back to the future and [ __ ]
aqua-blue tea yeah
I'm dressed to go to the beach and I
live in California it's more we're not
near the ocean though if I go to the
mall right now I'm gonna find one other
guy that's dressing like me and he's
probably in his 50s richest book and a
weird [ __ ] he's not weird you
know who is weird is the people that try
to act like normal people on TV [ __ ]
weirdos creepy that's psychopathic yup
those [ __ ]
as people hope you guys enjoyed that
video if you did a really cool way to
communicate that to us and for you to
never miss another video is by
subscribing so click on that little
subscribe button and you'll never miss
an episode for the next episode click
right up here